ce qui fait l'élection d'un député ce
qui fait l'élection d'un député qu'on
sous estime beaucoup c'est la
reconnaissance locale a parfois on
balaie d'un revers de main en disant ne
sont pas très importants aussi le lien
humain qu'on peut avoir avec ses
concitoyens c'est quand même un élément
essentiel de la politique politique
c'est pas qu'une affaire d'étiquettes et
je sais que les députés les républicains
sont parmi ceux qui sont le plus ancré
dans les territoires on s'attend à ce
que nous disparaissions et nous ne
disparaîtront pas parce que l'ancrage
des députés les républicains et d'une
véritable est une véritable puissance
électorale et vous le verrez j'en suis
certain lors des élections législatives